my name is Luis and I really like the
word curvy it's a great word used to
describe both women and roads but it
doesn't really apply to men so I went to
the streets of Hollywood to find out
what is the male equivalent to the word
curvy what do you think about the word
curvy I like it thick girls are my
favorite girls so I love the word I
actually thought we were talking about
an art project
when you say curvy like what do you mean
when you're describing someone as curvy
I think that there are negative and
positive interpretations of the word
when I hear it it's like voluptuous I
also don't think voluptuous is a
negative word it just sends a good
message to younger women that you don't
have to be a twig to be big or to be
influential you could be curvy I think
you know always put some meat on some on
that bone cuz I'm gonna eat it when
we're talking about the word curvy do
you attach that word to a certain gender
I feel like it's not as common to
describe men in that way I would never
call a dude curvy none can be curvy
I just think more to love it's four it's
what we should use for men I guess I
would say like he's a big dude is what I
would say like a dude I got ass like a
dude they got a stocky or bulky
well-rounded well grounded the point is
whatever your body type is just be happy
with it look at the mirror and say I
love Who I am and like that Christina
Aguilera song I'm beautiful in every
single way so it's just about owning
your body totally and letting me own
your body to body too